I couldn't have accomplished this
without everyone's help I feel like I
will find someone now time for
destruction an epic over-the-top DBZ
brawler is headed your way now a new
style of DBZ gameplay is here
powerful multiplayer modes powerful
warriors and powerful rivals Dragon Ball
Z battle of Z fight your way to the
story with your friends immerse yourself
in the DBZ world experience what makes
DBZ awesome the story of the sea
warriors unfolds in the form of heat
admissions experience a fierce battles
firsthand
team up with up to four players at any
point in the game and crease each
other's partner ranks to pull up even
more powerful moves connect with players
all over the world to enjoy various
styles of co-op gameplay
experience a variety of different
multiplayer modes join forces to defeat
the giant boss
form a four-player team for a team
battle or become rivals with everyone be
the last one standing in an eight-player
battle royale plus loads of other
missions are available online so many
ways to play from single-player up to 8
players
take full advantage of the four
different battle types use the Warriors
strength to turn the tides in your favor
please let me borrow a bit of your
energy increase your team's coordination
to raise the energy gauge this extreme
attack charges up in real time with the
power from the world
single-player missions co-op missions
rise to every challenge alone or with
friends
what
use the points our card you win to
customize your characters however you
want what is this
take on that overwhelmingly destructive
power
are we getting excited
I want you to fight with Saiyan cry get
ready for about that on this new
battlefield a legendary heated brawl
begins I have no choice I need to win
this this is the end easy this is fun
follow me
Dragon Ball Z battle looks G available
now day 1 additions include a bonus
download code for Goku's Naruto costume
try out various missions including
online missions in the free downloadable
demo carry on your safe data to the full
game it's your turn now to fight